let's go next to um
let's go to enrique from los angeles i
presume california
yes sir how are you i do good how you
doing thanks man
yeah just wanted to uh say like all the
racial stuff going on you know the
killings of the women and spas and all
that stuff
i just keep coming back to the same
point i don't know if it's kind of a
weird point but
i as a child i always felt that um as a
hispanic child she kind of job
i always felt and i felt and i knew that
all of these
since i was a kid republicans you know i
wasn't
when i was a kid it was reagan right and
that was the talking point
um i just always knew that it was always
based
around race you know that was in my
heart
everything all the rhetoric all the laws
uh you know the morality you know the
this bad abortions and the fact you know
i always felt in my heart i could be
wrong but i still feel the same way
today
you know and it's being exposed now um
because of how
um you know the republicans are just
saying it out loud you know but
it's just all about race but so give me
an example of that give me an example of
something that
is is all about race even though some
people might not realize it what's in it
like give me what are you talking about
well when the republicans talk about you
know
they want to protect uh the democracy
okay you know uh our great democracy and
then they're voting
you know they're voting uh they're
trying to put make voting harder
right that's all about race they're
giving you a reason for why they're
doing this a b and c
but the reality none of that is true
it's they don't want the country to
change
i think that there may be in some sense
it might be the reverse i mean
let me let me think this through so
there's no doubt that a lot of
republican voter suppression
is meant to make it more difficult for
minorities to vote
but that's because they know minorities
mostly aren't going to vote for them if
if they believed minorities were going
to vote for them
i think they would try to increase
minority voting i think it's
i think in some sense it might be
reverse reverse causation
well another example which i
i saw my cousins go through this you
know
they lived in a worse part of town than
i did here in l.a
um you know uh police the police
situation
yeah there's groups in lapd and
sheriff's department where there are
white nationalists
right well that's a problem not just in
la i mean white nationalism and law
enforcement is a yeah
that's a big problem yeah but what i'm
saying is it's
it's real it's infiltrated you know it's
real and for years and years and years
republicans were like
i mean i know it's fake i mean it's the
same republicans but i mean
the right wing conservatives that's it's
not true it's not true it's not real
it's real man like we're seeing it
unfold you know thanks to social media
and smartphones but
it's just a very deep sad part of
american life and as a brown person here
in america
you know i have an eight-year-old son
and we live in an area which is
asian and white and yeah you know it's
it's i have a hard time you know um
figuring out how to explain things to my
son and
you know it's just it's it's just race
is just
such a a big part of being a person of
color
um you know uh in america it's just
what's the question your son will ask
that you struggle to answer
uh well
there's been i mean i get nervous when i
talk to you so just forgive me but
that's okay
just like the let's see like he was
asking me a lot about
donald trump when he would hear me watch
the news or
a lot of his friends are donald trump
supporters and their parents are
and um you know when he would say
things my son would just pick up on
things he would pick up on things
that um like for example he spent the
night at one of his friends house and
we're we're christians he goes to a
christian school
and my son came home and told me that
his parents his little friend's
parents were saying things about asians
i'm just thinking about that right now
and that was like last year
in the beginning of the pandemic yeah i
was like yeah they were saying
i don't want to say what they were
saying but how do i explain that to my
son
you know what do i tell him you know
it's it's he goes you know
we're the only hispanic family uh we're
the second hispanic family in the whole
school
and it's really i thought about like
maybe not having him go there anymore
because
what's gonna happen when he gets older
right now he's a young innocent you know
little beautiful
child but you know when you get older
things
perceptions change and you know it's
it's yeah i mean it's like you almost
have to decide whether you feel like
you can warn him off in advance like
you're going to be hearing people
saying certain things but otherwise
you i'm guessing you'd be worried that
he'd be indoctrinated into stuff that
you find pretty ugly
i don't think indoctrinated no because i
mean i
actually i haven't thought of that
really but i think he'll he'll
you know no i'm not worried about that
but it's just a difficult situation
it really is and like the other caller
you know i agree with him
you know i'm a liberal and i'm a
democrat and i'm a progressive but
i'm also a christian you know you know
not full you know but i'm a christian
and
i really do think that um most
christians uh are okay are okay with
pretty much everything i mean uh
the whole abortion thing is such a huge
problem in getting more voters
over to to the left you know it's just
such a i don't know man i think there
could be some
middle ground there but i know it's very
difficult but i believe what he was
saying that we just
you know we should make things easier
for people to have
families i mean i went through something
like that i'm not gonna explain it's
personal but
there was a situation that uh somebody
in my family close
uh they had to make us you know anyway
but it's tough man but yeah definitely
the whole race thing as a person of
color
you know as an american of color it's in
it's in your face every single day man
and uh it's pretty pretty nuts agreed
all right my friend thank you for the
insights appreciate it
thanks man all right here we go